hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem 99 videos lang ich
gemacht habe ich mir gedacht ich gehe
heute mal wieder auf die überzeit teste
dich und schauen wir da ein paar tests
an und ihr seht schon julien band
enthält also wir finden heute raus ob
wir julian benzin sind oder nicht du
bist ein richtiger julian bender dann
beweise also ich liebe du und du
wahrscheinlich
natürlich tue ich bin ist alles erlaubt
juli 14 peking lips allawi herzlich
irgendwie nehmen diese tests videos eben
immer die oberhand über meinen körper
und die fans kamen pascal überhaupt
nicht mehr falls ihr euch übrigens mag
muss diese skizze hier gibt das ist
ultra plausch ich glaube das wird nix
dort die erste frage bei wem wohnte you
frühjahr bei christian und anderen kann
man es schon immer in köln in berlin und
frankfurt hat weiß ich wurde er gewohnt
hat die fragen sind immer so blöd
definiert ich meine was früher wer von
euch weiß ob du nicht mit zwei monaten
mal in frankfurt gelegt hat weil
mutter irgendwie daherkommt oder sogar
ein zuwachs der lieblingsbaum der küste
vor cabrio stupid blumen ticks wenn du
das video gerade sie interessanter name
blumenkind ist echt cool ich glaube
nicht dass du schon immer in köln
gewohnt hat und ich weiß auch nicht ob
er in berlin oder frankfurt gewonnen
deswegen würde ich sagen ja bei eltern
gewohnt wenn das schon als erstes dort
steht und das so kraft ausformuliert ist
zu wem oder was hat eine sinnliche
verbindung zum wurst zu der sonne zu den
sternen zu den mond fusion john rutter
fakt ist ich hab ja seine softbox hier
stehen das ist diese softbox die steht
hier und beleuchtet mich quasi
allerdings machte in letzter zeit alles
außer ihren job ich weiß ja wie es ab
und zu hören aber die knallt die ganze
drum ich habe aber auch schon eine neue
bestellt also kam ribery ich würde sagen
dass du eine sinnliche beziehung bzw
verbindung zu dem
und den sternen und der seit 1 der hat
doch irgendwie tattoos von dem kram ich
bekomm ich würde wirklich sagen dem mond
weil ich weiss glaube ich dass er davon
ihre tastaturen von dem montag übrigens
einen tanktop weil es 34 grad sind ich
muss mich ja irgendwie mal rechtfertigen
von ein paar leuten hier von wegen
rottweil der muskeln gut dass kein
tanktop tragen aber hey es ist heißt
deswegen wie viele abonnenten hat er
zurzeit auf youtube stand dritte achtet
2016 ich würde sagen 25 millionen ich
weiß dass er mehr hat als ich allerdings
gilt diese verfickte lampe
das ist eines von juice hobbys jimmy
jeden tag sagen dass er cool wäre das
wird mit doppel s geschrieben liebes
blumen camps durch blumen diesen
definitiv nicht blumenwiese hüpfen wein
artig wird trotzdem sagen tanzen und
singen
ich würde auch sagen dass eines seiner
hobbys zu essen weil von geben menschen
das hobby es zu essen weil ein hobby ist
der tätigkeit die man gerne macht und
öfter macht und man ist doch gern und
man
ist doch öfter das blumenkind oder
allgemein alle texte die hersteller
immer finde ich mindestens um 20 sachen
und jedem christi mit dumm oder schlecht
definiert deswegen bitte
die alte ist woher soll ich das wissen
viereinhalb man sieht auch dass den 47
90 jahre ich schätze so 326 jahre 20.30
uhr ist das jetzt schwierig eine lösung
zu finden mit dem wohnt er in einer wg
stand dritte achtet 2016 ich würde sagen
mit john chidsey vintz wie man sieht nur
an seinen videos irgendwie so richtig
viele leute durch seine wohnung laufen
deswegen habe ich jetzt gemacht er wurde
mit mehreren zusammen die ich würde
sagen mit vince weil ich glaube schenkt
und stephan zusammen und her welche wg
dennis irgendwie keine richtige antwort
aus welchem land stammt ursprünglich aus
portugal schweiz russland singapur
deutschland ich weiß es nicht ob er
wirklich in deutschland geboren ist ich
würde einfach sagen singer pur weil
diese asiatische raum ist ich muss
wirklich sagen es ist das letzte video
wo diese lampe diese bescheuerte lampe
lässt danach werde ich der eine klatsche
geben halt doch deine schnauze damals
schon eine neue lampe stellt dies
unterwegs kommt morgen an golf ein
wie heißt der kanal den er zusammen mit
bau für die über films bei juba juba
juba die der tatsächlichen cooler kanal
name des ding heißt you a films isch
oder tuba
ich bin nicht ob da noch was neues
dieses land ist der kanal wo john und
sind regelmäßig videos hochladen
die reister kleinkinder station wenn
schon halt dein maul ein paar sekunden
später ok ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
hab grad gebügelt um das herauszufinden
ich hätte jetzt mit spent two brothers
gesagt weil keiner nämlich
reis presse um keinen platz ist ja schon
seit einem jahr oder so wir da nichts
mehr hochgeladen
deswegen hat band of brothers es tut mir
leid ich habe mich bei dieser frage
geschummelt letzte frage hat utah jazz
ja überall sogar im gesicht er hat keine
jahr an armen und brust darunter werden
grad bilder von eingeblendeten von
anderen kurses deswegen sieht man dass
er keine tattoos im gesicht hat deswegen
würde ich sagen ja an armen und groß und
wir kriegen einfach mal auf auswertungen
omg das hast du super gemacht
anscheinend bis zu ein großer julian
fans die haben zehn von zehn aufgaben
richtig beantwortet nicht mal bei einem
quiz über mich selbst hatte ich so viel
richtig an dieser stelle ich ihnen meine
damen und männer gefallen hat die märkte
sollten last auf jeden fall weiter
schreibt alle ohne die kommentare julien
wenn ihr keine ahnung